>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Anne McLean: It's been a joy
to present Meredith Monk here
at the Library of Congress.
[ Applause ]
A joy to hear you particularly
here in our hall.
Such a beautiful clarity.
We talked a little bit
earlier today, very briefly,
about the exhilarating and dizzying
course of the last year for you,
celebrating fifty years of composing
and performing the
residency that you --
>> Meredith Monk: I
started when I was two.
>> Anne McLean: Two --
[ Laughter ]
And your mother was a singer, right?
>> Meredith Monk: Yes.
>> Anne McLean: Yea.
And most recently, of course,
receiving the National Medal of Arts
from President Obama, what has that
been like for you, the intensity
and the sheer number of events and
also, what's your trajectory now?
>> Meredith Monk: What
was before the trajectory?
I'm sorry.
I missed it.
>> Anne McLean: What has
it been like for you?
You talked about just the feelings.
>> Meredith Monk: Well, getting the
National Medal from President Obama,
I'm still shaking from it.
I'll never forget it in my lifetime
and a beautiful human being,
and yea, I mean, really,
when they called me up,
I was shaking for a few hours.
It's sort of beyond your-- you know,
you just do your work, basically.
So you know, something
like that happens,
it's kind of beyond your
dreams or, you know?
I mean, you are just step
by step doing your work.
So it was a magical day.
But the 50th year was really
interesting because, you know,
it was a way for me to also
look back over many, many,
many different aspects of my work.
I was the Debs Composer
Residence at Carnegie Hall
and so we did six concerts,
different concerts,
at Carnegie Hall really
emphasizing the variety of the work.
Like for about the last
15 years I've been trying
to work a little bit more
with instrumental ensembles
like an orchestra or chamber groups,
mostly with voice, but you know,
because that is my instrument.
But I did try.
I did a premiere piece for a very
wonderful ensemble called the ACJW,
which is the Academy Carnegie
Juilliard Wild ensemble,
and they get a stipend
for two years.
It's young musicians who want
to play chamber music mostly,
and they're very, very
fine, fine musicians.
So I thought, you know,
bite the bullet.
Don't put a voice in there.
I mean that would be the way
I would feel more secure,
and why don't you just use the
seven instruments and so, you know,
the old days, is it my braid, is
it my-- you know the old days,
when we had these things and
that was a great experience,
and then I did my ensemble.
The last concert was a real
beautiful potpourri of music from,
for 50 years, and there was a one
four hour marathon where a bunch
of different musicians that I love
and that I know did their versions
of my music, which was very -- that
was very special including Leonardo
from Sonic Youth, and you
know, DJ Spooky, Missy Mazzoli.
There were, you know, a
lot of different people.
So that was very special.
And then we also performed
On Behalf of Nature,
which was my last large multimedia
music theater piece at BAM,
and that does include movement and
light, and it has eight performers
in it and was basically about what
we're losing, in danger of losing.
>> Anne McLean: I wish we
had the space for that here.
Back to your chamber
music for a moment.
Do you have any plans?
We're in the business
of chamber music
so anything we should know about?
>> Meredith Monk: I have a piece in
mind but it probably would be more
for a chamber size orchestra,
maybe in voices and right now,
I'm working on a new
piece with Allison
and Katie called, Cellular Songs.
It's right now, three -- So far I've
done four little A Cappella pieces,
but it will grow from there.
But I'm very interested.
I've always used the
voice as an instrument,
and now I've been really interested
in using the instruments as voices.
So I've learned a lot about that and
then it goes back into my ensemble
because the whole ensemble also
includes John Hollenbeck who's a
fantastic multi-percussionist,
and so some of the richness
of the instrumental writing that I
find with working with an orchestra
or something like that, I can put
it right back into the ensemble.
So I think it's grown in that way
and you know, when you're an artist,
you just want to keep
growing and growing.
That's basically my goal of
life is to hopefully be growing
until the day I die and be working.
>> Anne McLean: I read a comment
from the critic, Tom Service,
the British critic, saying
that he felt that you wanted
to give your listeners a vision
of concentration and attention
in an ever diminishing and be in
an increasing speed of the world
and diminishing attention circle.
>> Meredith Monk: Yes because we
are definitely victims of weapons
of mass distraction, which
is what Gary Snyder said,
and I think it's so true.
So I think that the live performance
is such a wonderful opportunity.
First of all, we're all here in
the same space in the same time
and that's unusual and I feel
that we're losing sense of touch
and we're even losing the sense of
being able to look at each other
in the eyes and not
have the thumbs going.
I always say, I think generations
from now, people are going
to have hands like
this and big thumbs.
You know, no fingers.
It's just going to be thumbs.
So, you know, I feel like the live
performance we're very vulnerable
and that's unusual
also in the culture.
It's not smoothed over in any way.
We could fall.
We could sing the wrong note.
It's like a tight rope a little
bit and it's very important
to affirm our human sense of touch
and connection and I think that --
and then also the concentration
thing too.
It's not -- it's just about
being able to let go of that part
of your mind that's always
narrating your life, and now I think
because of the devices of mass
distraction, we even have more irony
and quotation marks and brackets
and it just goes more and more.
You know, so we're looking at this,
looking at this, looking at this,
looking at this; how
about direct experience?
So I think that the live
performance has that possibility.
[ Applause ]
>> Anne McLean: Well, we'd like
to open this up a little bit
and I believe we have
some microphones
that are already going around.
It might be a little
hard to see you.
Does anyone have a question?
[ Inaudible ]
Do you want to speak?
>> Meredith Monk: I think maybe --
[ Inaudible Question ]
I haven't done computer digital,
kind of that media at this point.
But, I mean, now I'm
speaking through a microphone.
You know, I go into
the recording studio
and they use a computer even though
-- you know, I've worked for ECM
and Manfred Eicher is cursing
the computer all the time.
So I don't know.
I mean, I guess my instinct has
been to go more towards the --
I feel like the voice can do
anything and that I guess I go more
and more, keep on doing this
acoustic kind of idea as much
as I can as a sort of anecdote
because there's plenty of that,
you know, in the world but it's not
that I'm closed to the possibility.
If there was something where
it transcended itself somehow,
you know, where it's
not what it's about
but actually it kind of
goes beyond in a way.
I mean I use film in my pieces and
you know, video, that kind of thing,
but I haven't done that kind of you
know, computer web kind of idea yet.
I'm always open to anything
though at any point.
[ Inaudible Question ]
Yes.
Yes, I mean, well, it's funny.
I had a voice teacher and
I still study to this day,
but this voice teacher -- I remember
I was singing at Carnegie Hall,
and I was doing some of
these songs from The Hill,
and I didn't have a microphone,
and you know it was so beautiful,
the voice in acoustic
space which I really love.
And he, a voice teacher of all
things, you know, opera teacher
and everything, he said,
you should use a microphone
because then you get to hear
the little nuances and clicks
so you know -- or the little,
very subtle kinds of things.
And so, I mean, we could easily, in
this beautiful room that has a lot
of grain to it, we could certainly
sing without a microphone,
but sometimes you don't want to push
because if you push past it
you don't get also the little,
tiny detail.
So that's usually why
I use a microphone,
but in a room that's very
live and a very small room,
we would go without
a microphone easily.
There's a very beautiful
upstate New York,
in East Meredith New York there's
a beautiful old church That has --
It's all wood, and you know, it's
so beautiful with the acoustics.
You really don't want to
have a microphone with it.
[ Inaudible Question ]
Yes that's a khaen gao, a khaen
gao, which is a Laotian instrument.
[ Inaudible Question ]
Well, Bohdan Hilash has a collection
of so many instruments, you know,
so many flutes and you know,
he's also one of the really great
contra base clarinet players
and contra base saxophone players.
There aren't too many
of them, and he --
you know, one of the most wonderful
things about working with Bohdan is
that he has this incredible range of
instruments and instrumental skills,
and so when we're working
on something we try
to find what the best
sound would be for that.
>> Thank you.
>> Meredith Monk: You
are very welcome.
I mean I was going to tell him to
come out but he may be downstairs.
He could tell you.
On Behalf of Nature we
use a tiny, little flute.
At the very beginning, he
uses the contra base clarinet.
He uses a base clarinet and a
regular B flat clarinet and I mean,
all kinds of things in the piece.
>> Anne McLean: Yes?
[ Inaudible Question ]
>> Meredith Monk: Yes.
It's very close to what you
have to do with a Jew's harp.
With a Jew's harp, I change
the inside cavity of my mouth
to make the different
tones that you hear
over the fundamental Jew's harp.
So basically, I'm keeping --
it's actually not so relaxed.
You have to keep that fundamental
and you close off some of the places
in here so that it isolates
that overtone so that midrange,
you are not hearing so much.
You are hearing the fundamental
and then by closing off,
and actually it's coming
through here.
You hear that overtone,
and actually, in some ways,
you hear overtones
better with a men's voice
because you know sometimes we're
actually singing our fundamental
pretty high than our overtone, you
can't -- it's not human hearing.
I was singing that
song pretty high today
and so I was getting a different
kind of overtone than I might
if I was singing a half a
tone lower or tone lower.
[ Inaudible Question ]
Yes.
Well, first of all, my mother
was a jingle singer on the radio.
She was the original Muriel Cigar,
Blue Bonnet margarine,
Schaefer Beer.
My grandfather was a base
baritone from Russia.
And he came from the United
States and then sang in all kinds
of places, Carnegie
Hall, Brooklyn Academy.
He would do concerts
with a contralto,
base baritone and contralto.
That's unusual.
And then he opened
a music conservatory
up in Washington Heights.
So that side of the family
and I heard my great
grandfather was a cantor in Russia
so that singing thing was something
that was very natural for me.
Movement was quite hard
because I have strabismus,
an eye thing where I can't fuse
two images and my mother heard
about Dalcroze Eurhythmics.
So my earliest training was
in Dalcroze Eurhythmics,
which is an integration of
the body, and you learn music
through the body, but I think I
learned my body through music,
so but I was moving a lot
as a child dancing too.
So I have a combined background in
music and in dance and also theater.
So I think that that's also
partially why when I had
that revelation at the piano
doing regular classical exercises
that I realized, the voice can
also be a nonverbal instrument.
I think coming from a movement
background, I trusted that.
I trusted that nonverbal
communication is very deep,
and at Sarel [assumed spelling]
Arts, I was in the voice department.
I studied classical singing leader,
opera workshop, and then when I came
to New York, my pieces were more
gesture based; a little bit of voice
and very cinematic
kind of structures,
and I was missing singing.
And so I just sat down at the
piano and started vocalizing,
and I had this revelation
and from that point on,
my life really changed, and
the revelation also included
that within the voice could be male
and female, different landscapes,
characters, ages, different
ways of producing sound.
I felt that it was a very --
I instinctively felt that it was a
very deep and ancient instrument.
It could delineate feelings
and shades of feelings
for which we don't have words.
And it also, strangely enough, was
a way of coming back to my family
because being in a bunch
of singer family, you know,
a family with a bunch of singers,
it's kind of hard to find your spot.
So and I had done a lot of
choreography at that point
and I had -- because of
my physical limitations,
I had to find my own vocabulary
which was a blessing, you know,
that I found my own way of finding
movement so I knew how to work
so that when I had the
revelation with the voice,
I knew to go into the studio and
I knew how to work with my voice
and I had a more wide range,
you know, you could say,
virtuosic instrument as a singer.
So it was like I came home
when I had that revelation
and it's been all these years
thinking of the voice and the body
as one, because I think that our
singing style is very kinetic.
And then like Katie didn't
come from a movement background
but she's a wonderful
mover so you know, it's --
we come from different
backgrounds with the ensemble.
>> Anne McLean: Maybe just
one or two more questions.
Maybe here.
>> I think there's a lot of interest
in the way you produce different
sounds, but I was curious
about one aspect of it as
to learning how to do that
or spending time alone in New Mexico
or wherever, your way you do that,
about the evolution of your ability
to make this a different sound.
How does that work for you and are
you able to hear yourself working
or do you have to take that
out and teach yourself?
>> Meredith Monk: It's
very interesting.
Oh, well there's actually two or
three different questions in there.
One is the listening, which is --
I mean in a way, the older I get the
more I realize that I actually live
through my ears and I've just been
more and more just enjoying sitting,
especially when I'm in New Mexico
because I don't have traffic
and everything going by.
Sometimes I just sit like
I feel like I'm like a dog.
I'm like --
[ Laughter ]
You know how dogs just sit there?
And I just listen and you know, I've
always been more a doer than a be-er
so I'm learning how to be.
I also have meditation practice,
which is helping me learn how to be
but I just sit there and
listen and I'm just so stunned
by the cosmic conductor, you know,
in nature, how sounds come and go,
and I guess I've always
felt very close to that.
And then as far as hearing
myself, I mean I do hear myself.
I don't have to go outside to teach
it to someone else and hear it.
I do tape myself, you know,
or notate what I'm doing.
But it's a funny question that
you would ask because I think
at certain times in all of our lives
as singers, there's a certain point
where you have to kind of
relearn that coordination
of hearing yourself in
relation to what's around you.
You know, sometimes you
lose that coordination
so you are either not hearing what's
around you enough or you are hearing
or you are not hearing yourself
enough so really the, you know,
staying in tune and everything is
doing both simultaneously; listening
and being able to hear yourself.
So sometimes, I give in my
workshop like an exercise
like that where you are singing.
It's like the big group of
people and you choose a tone
and everybody chooses a tone.
At the same time, you are
listening to the whole thing,
and you choose somebody else's
tone when you finish yours
so that it keeps on shifting, you
know it's kind of like a big cluster
that keeps on shifting and so that's
that thing of being able to --
and also when you sing with groups,
like say choral pieces or something
like that or groups, I always
say if you only hear yourself,
you are singing too loud because
one of the most wonderful things
about singing with other people
is hearing the other people.
That's a pleasure of it.
>> Thank you.
>> Meredith Monk: Wonderful
question, thank you.
All of the questions were wonderful.
Thank you.
Appreciate it.
>> Anne McLean: Maybe that
might be it for the evening.
A glorious evening.
>> Meredith Monk: Thank you.
>> Anne McLean: Master of
the voice; Meredith Monk.
>> Meredith Monk: [Laughs]
Thank you.
Thank you very, very much.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.